then suddenly I saw it with only a
slight turning to mask its rise to the
surface the things slid into view above
the dark waters have asked Polyphemus
lichen loathesome it darted like a
stupendous monster of nightmares to the
monolith about which had flung it
gigantic scaly arms the while it bowed
its hideous head and gave vent to
certain measured sounds I think I went
mad then Dagon is a deity that I've
mentioned in passing and some of you may
recall the narration of Lovecraft short
story titled Dagon but surprisingly
enough I haven't made a video devoted to
this particular character the first rule
descriptions we get of Dagon appear in
Lovecraft short story titled after a
deity written in July 1917 and later
published in the November issue of the
vagrant magazine in 1919 in this
particular story our narrator is an
unnamed morphine addicted man who
recounts his experience when his cargo
ship is captured by a German sea Raider
during World War one
he eventually manages to escape on a
lifeboat but ends up drifting aimlessly
but he does notice the water resembles a
horrid black sludge and is littered with
the carcasses of decaying fish
eventually the seabed becomes dry enough
to walk on and after several days he
comes across a gigantic monolith made of
white stone or the aquatic hieroglyphics
edged onto it
the narrator then describes sculptures
of figures that he believes to be men
but who also resembled fish almost
worship in this monolith this of course
refers back to the deep ones but perhaps
not the ones we see in shadow of
Innsmouth these figures are described as
being similar in size to a whale this
may be referring back to the ancient
deep ones which were also called Dagon
likely because they were much larger in
size similar to the deity they worshiped
the narrator then describes a vast
Polyphemus like stupendous monster of
nightmares with large scaly arms and a
hideous head
seeing this creature wrap itself around
monolith the narrator then flees for his
life into a great storm we don't know
for sure if the figure he saw was Dagon
himself or just an ancient deep one but
we are led to believe that the man's
descent into madness and drug addiction
came from witnessing the great deep one
in Dagon is mentioned quite often
throughout lacrosse work and sometimes
he goes by the name of Father Dagon who
along with mother Hydra are all over the
Deep Ones also were led to believe we
know Dagon was considered a great old
one but we don't know exactly what he
looked like other than a gigantic scaly
and fibia humanoid so you are free to
use your own imagination to a certain
degree Dagon is of course worshipped by
the Deep Ones but he does also have a
human cult located back in Innsmouth
known as the esoteric order of Dagon
which perform rituals to appease the
Deep Ones as well as their leader
there is one theory that claims Dagon
wasn't always a deity and he may have
once been a regular deep one until he
was chosen by the star spawn of Cthulhu
the star spawn were known for selecting
individuals from a species and then
given them the ability to protect and
empower the rest of that species they
normally only select the most impressive
specimens what they saw in Dagon however
and why they do this
we don't know it's possible that
Lovecraft drew his inspiration from
Dagon the Mesopotamian god of fertility
as well as Dagon the Philistine god of
agriculture that also features in the
Old Testament there was also the
misinterpretation of the God's name in
Hebrew during the Iron Age which led to
him being seen as the god of fish so I
guess it does make some sense that the
god of fish became Lovecraft's God of
weird fish men hybrids I honestly don't
really know trying too hard to make
sense of love cross work seems to be a
fast track down the path of insanity and
I guess that's what he intended so
before I do go insane and anger any more
fish people I guess I'll end the video
here feel free to share any thoughts
with me in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained